as democratic state lawmakers remain in
washington tonight trying to avoid
votes back home on republican-backed
election reform legislation
this comes as the gop is bashing
president biden's comments yesterday
accusing republicans of trying to
subvert the election process
and assault he said on the democracy
white house correspondent peter ducey
has details live tonight from the north
lawn good evening peter good evening
brett there are new questions about when
democrats
like the filibuster and when democrats
don't like it for example here in
washington d.c democrats are in
the senate majority they don't need it
and they're talking about maybe getting
rid of it
but those texas democrats are in the
minority there and
their trip to dc amounts to a filibuster
we're going to stay out until the
session is over to kill this bill
that could be weeks who is paying for
all of this
all this is entirely funded through
donations
so specifics about donors remain unknown
even though a big part of that federal
bill these texas democrats are lobbying
for
is transparency the for the people act
is about
ensuring the freedom of people to vote
getting dark money out of politics
the for the people act is the federal
law president biden hopes
stops states from tightening voting
regulations
bullies and merchants of fear peddlers
of lies
are threatening the very foundation of
our country
top republicans are balking at the
historical parallels
these false comparisons are an insult
to the actual hurdles that americans
have overcome the co-founder of black
voters matter was hoping to hear the
president say
in that big speech he'd get rid of the
filibuster
if it meant passing voting rights
legislation but the president didn't say
it so
cliff albright tweets the speech was an
epic
fail white house officials want any
calls about removing the filibuster to
be made
by senators it's up to them to vote on
what their processes will be
moving forward some republicans are
skeptical the voting rights bill favored
by democrats is about access to polls
at all it is designed to keep democrats
in power the next hundred years the
filibuster was defended by
senator biden when he represented
delaware but times
are changing and so too are tactics like
the ones being used
by the runaway texas democrats do you
know
any of any examples from his 36 years
in the senate that joe biden just hopped
on a train
and left town to avoid a vote that he
knew he was going to lose
welcome back um look i think that the
president's view
is that these texas legislators
were making a statement uh through
action
so the president there is supportive of
these democrats leaving the state even
though he ran
on a platform of being a bipartisan
deal maker tomorrow another campaign
promise he made is going to be tested
that he can patch up relationships with
america's allies and that will happen
when
the german chancellor angela merkel
comes here
right whenever you get the welcome back
that's a good sign peter thank you